olha só alguns programas que não me
deixam dormir novamente na amazônia
às vezes só não vai falta de água de
forma que todos vocês vão ver comigo que
a gente precisa resolver esse problema
amanhã todas as minhas fichas em uma
tecnologia que usa tecnologia de uma
ameaça que inclui problemas resolvidos
por jovens jovens de 14 e 15 anos e 75
mas a gente ainda elogia a gente
continuar colocando ela como um
conhecimento que só um grupo seleto de
meninos brancos consegue construir isso
começar com 50 dia quando eu abro a
minha caixa de e-mails de uma menina que
tem 18 anos
ela pode entrar na faculdade porque ela
não é esse
uma menina que tem 18 anos acho que não
tem gente aprendeu uma tecnologia comum
é totalmente à vontade eu tomei essa
missão pra mim com 18 anos eu queria
pegar essa entidade administradora e
transformar uma coisa leve livre e solta
neste gênero de raça poder aquisitivo
todo mundo mais folhas
além dos elogios ano a tecnologia de
imagens dela na internet que não queria
aquilo
a minha missão começou na faculdade
no meu primeiro ano meu famoso primeiro
dia de aula
a idéia é só mais um dia da mulher da
minha vida eu entrei na sala de aula
sentei nada
um professor de algoritmo criado para o
padrão e eu não tinha vendido há
problema
eu sei que gostei disso meu pai
trabalhou na chapa que no máximo mas
ninguém no bairro o técnico neneca não
vai fazer eletrônica menina não parava
no final de semana computador do pai mas
todo mundo que estava em volta de mim
tinha na verdade não tinha grande cara
tinha 24 anos mas o local é de fato não
vai disputar todo mundo já sabe fazer
isso aí começou a luta assim se
intensificou mas quando eu achei a foto
da primeira turma que tinha se formado
no instituto de matemática e estatística
da universidade de são paulo que é um
lugar de muita gente foi adaptar
ela era de 1981 foi construída
o dia que tinha feito curso ali eram
mulheres
ninguém sabia disso eu sabia que aquilo
me motiva de uma maneira um contexto de
voto mulher na computação que começou
com uma melhora minha que é o goiano
comigo no banheiro com muitas outras
meninas teve um bom dia com ele por
muito tempo não foi mulheres e uma
menina mas uma menina que queria
revolucionar uma menina que se aliou à
tecnologia que sempre foi feminista
coral jovem idealista mas que não tinha
a menor idéia de como aliada simples que
era da tecnologia podia dominar o mundo
o blog cresceu foi reconhecido
internacionalmente é mas a minha métrica
nunca foi visualização que é o que todo
mundo pergunta mas sim quantos e mails
recebi na minha caixa por semana de
meninas que tinham a trajetória alterada
tinham terminado a faculdade que me
mandava o convite de formatura primeira
formatura delas porque eu tinha ajudado
de alguma maneira o blog nunca me trouxe
um tostão mas ele me apresentou muita
gente gente que pensava como eu queria
mudar o mundo como eu em 2013
eu tive a oportunidade de me envolver
com o projeto que já existia nos estados
unidos e que já estava grande lá e
queria crescer aqui no brasil nome era
techno vexante além disso era um desafio
de empreendedorismo tecnologia só para
meninas
nossa missão era pegar meninas que
queriam resolver problemas e transformar
elas em agente de transformação no
primeiro ano a gente não tinha um tostão
a gente tinha vontade de idealismo tinha
trabalho voluntário de um brasil inteiro
queria ajudar a gente ea gente conseguiu
mudar a vida de quase 400 meninas
no segundo a gente cresceu recebeu
investimento ea gente mudou a vida de
mais 1600 meninas
eu tive a sorte de ver mais duas meninas
pelo brasil se transformando agente de
transformação querendo fazer a diferença
podendo fazer a diferença
bom até aí eu achava que eu ia conseguir
seguir uma trajetória profissional meio
comum queria terminar o mestrado
trabalhar na nasa que será um sonho
mexer com satélites negócio embarcado lá
fiz isso de a graduação inteira me
formei no período ideal estava tudo indo
bem até que outra coisa incrível que foi
um divisor de águas
tocou o telefone e era um recrutador do
google falando
a minha é boa aluna né e aí então a fim
de passar uma temporada na califórnia
trabalhar com algoritmos aqui conheceu
ecossistema agente geral não falar
nessas coisas em dólar é comer de graça
casa comida roupa lavada né
a gente vai fiz o processo seletivo e
fui na real foi a melhor coisa que
aconteceu na minha vida porque foi aí
caiu minha ficha que eu podia trabalhar
com educação que na real na real não era
bem que podia que não ia ter outro jeito
eu só ia ser feliz se eu fizesse aquilo
a gente chegava todo dia de manhã tomava
um cafezinho um delícia dado de graça
era ótimo ea gente passava o dia
discutindo tecnologia entendendo como
que a gente podia colocar mais meninas
da tecnologia como que a gente podia
transformar a missão de construir uma
aplicação numa missão que qualquer
pessoa podia fazer o que qualquer pessoa
podia tirar alguma coisa que ela tinha
na cabeça e construir com tecnologia
afetar mas um milhão de pessoas e além
de tudo a gente programava que é
incrível a vida parecia ottawa uma
beleza estava ótimo
era a vida que todo mundo sonhava com 20
e poucos anos com 21 anos trabalhando a
melhor empresa do mundo ganhem dólar
como é de graça
enfim eu decidi voltar pro brasil
essa minha visão de mundo acabou virando
capa de revista é falei por aí consegui
é mostrar um pouco do que eu pensava do
que o sentido que eu queria fazer
a gente começou a maratona de
aplicativos em 2014 uma maneira mais
enxuta instalável e eu vi de novo
jovens mudando a educação deles mesmos
percebendo que eles não tinham que
consumir uma educação que estava
encaixotada numa apostila que ele podia
criar que ele podia ele transformar a
educação
eu vi gente da comunidade ribeirinha no
portal da amazônia me perguntar o que
era geladeira mas tem um smartphone e eu
falar de matsapa internet wifi facebook
e não levanta a mão pra perguntar nada
percebi que eu precisava fazer isso bom
a essa altura já devem ter sacado que eu
desisti da nasa a trazer o mestrado e
desistir da nasa não não foi uma coisa
fácil mas eu percebi que não ia ter
jeito sabe eu ia fazer aquilo ia fazer
aquilo não tinha mais jeito a gente fala
quem trabalha com educação assim como a
gente viu natal que a gente brinca que o
mosquito e aí não tem mais jeito aí
não tem como sair não tem um remédio
ainda que cure tudo isso na maratona a
gente viu o ano passado mais de 1600
crianças espalhadas pelo país fazendo
aplicativos para mudar a própria
educação
a gente trouxe gente para são paulo que
nunca tinha andado de avião e percebeu
que a tecnologia era isso podia mudar a
vida deles drasticamente assim como
mudou a minha e era isso que eu queria
fazer
esse ano a maratona está rolando a
maratona de aplicativos e eu espero que
a gente consiga atingir mais de 10.000
fez no verão
bom isso tudo me faz pensar que um
estado que se contar eu voltei para o
mestrado gente mas eu troquei
completamente meu tema do mestrado que
tinha a ver com satélites foguetes e
softwares embarcados e agora tem a ver
com o técnico em educação e tecnologia
o que eu quero fazer é descobrir um
jeito de ensinar o mundo
a entender ainda que básico que é que a
tecnologia de maneira enxuta escalava
espero que eu consiga descobrir até o
ano que vem né porque é o prazo que tem
torçam por mim é bom mas tudo isso me
faz pensar é que o sucesso é um conceito
muito relativa
para muita gente é ganhar muito dinheiro
é trabalhar uma grande corporação é
passar num concurso público é ter uma
vida estável
pra mim o sucesso nunca foi nunca vai
ser isso pra mim sucesso até propósito
pra mim sucesso é fazer é começar a
resolver esses problemas
mais do que isso é ajudar as pessoas a
eu aposto coloca a mão no fogo que é
mais fácil ensinar programação
tecnologia para o mundo do que tentar
resolver todos os problemas do mundo
essa é uma estratégia para mudar o mundo
não vou conseguir fazer sozinha
bom eu vou continuar tentando mudar o
mundo uma linha de código por vez uma
menina por mês um problema por vez
um ser humano por vez muito obrigada